one of the things I discovered on Reddit
and Discord of anonymity or pseudonyms
or usernames that don't represent the
actual name I'll slack is an example of
one because I think I did a I used to
have a slack for like deep learning
course that I was teaching and I was
like very large like 20 000 people
whatever
but so you could grow quite large but
there's a culture of like I'm going to
represent my actual identity my actual
name and turn the same stuff on Discord
I think I was the only [ __ ] using my
actual name on there it's like everybody
was using uh pseudonyms so what's what's
the role of that in the online community
well so I actually gave a talk on this a
few years ago called uh the pseudonymous
economy okay and um it's come back
faster than I expected uh but I did
think it was going to come about fairly
fast and essentially the concept is
obviously we've had so first antonym
pseudonym real name right can you
describe the difference between
difference Anonymous is like 4chan uh
where there's no tracking of a name
you're you know there's your reputation
associated with an identity right
pseudonymous is like much of Reddit
where there's a persistent username and
it has Karma over time but it's not
linked to a the global identifier that
is your state name all right so your
quote real name even the term real name
by the way is a misnomer because it's
like your Social Security name like
social security number it's your
official government name it's your it's
your state name it is the tracking
device it's a it's an air tag that's put
on you right why do I say that right
another word for a name is a handle and
so just visualize like a giant file
cabinet there's a handle with Lex
Freeman on it that anybody the billions
of people around the world can go up to
and they can pull this file on you out
images of you things you said like
billions of people can stalk billions of
other people now that's a very new thing
and I actually think this will be a
transitional era in like human history
we're actually going to go back into a
much more encrypted world
another way to see
real names is the label on a thing that
can be canceled yes that's right in fact
there's a book called seeing like a
state which actually talks about the
origins of surnames and whatnot like if
you have a guy who is that guy with
brown hair that's like an analog
identifier it could be in 10 different
people in a village but if you have a
first name last name okay that guy can
now be conscripted you can go down with
a list a list of digital identifiers
pull that guy out pull him you know into
the military for conscription right so
that was like one of the purposes of
names was to make masses of humans
legible to a state right and seeing like
a state you can see them now right see
digital identifiers one thing that
people don't usually think about is
pseudonymity is itself a form of
decentralization so you know people know
Satoshi Nakamoto was pseudonymous they
also know he's into decentralization but
one way of thinking about it is let's
say his real name okay or his state name
is a node okay attached to that is uh
every database you know his uh his Gmail
his you know Facebook if he had one
every government record on him right all
of these databases
have that state name as the foreign key
right
um and so it can go and look things up
in all of those uh databases right and
so they think of it as being the center
of a giant network of all of these
things when you go and create a
pseudonym you're butting off a totally
new node that's far away from all the
rest and now he's choosing to attach
bitcoinetalk and bitcoin.org and the GPT
signatures of the code if you choose to
do that
all those things digital signatures are
all attached to this new decentralized
name because he's instantiating it not
the government right when we're thinking
about it is the root administrator of
the quote real name system is the state
because you cannot simply edit your name
there right you can't just go you can't
log into usa.gov and backspace your name
and change it moreover
um your birth certificate all these
stuff that's fixed and immutable right
whereas we take for granted that on
every site you go to you can backspace
you can be like call me Ishmael you know
walk into a site you use whatever name
you want you just have to use the same
Name Across multiple sites you can do
that and if not you don't have to one
thing that we're seeing now actually is
at the level of kids you know the
younger generation
um Eric Schmidt several years ago
mentioned that you know people would
like change their names when they became
adults so that they could do that this
is kind of already happening people are
using I've marked on this many years ago
search resistant identities okay why
they have their finsta which is their
quote fake name Instagram
and rinsta which is their real name
Instagram this is cool okay and what's
interesting is on their rinsta they're
their fake self because they're in their
Sunday Best and you know smiling and
this is the one that's meant to be
search indexed right on the finsta
with their fake name this is just shared
with their closest friends they're their
real self and they're you know hanging
out at parties or whatever you know and
so this way they've got something which
is the public Persona and the private
Persona right the public Persona that's
search indexed and the private Persona
that is private for friends right and so
organically people are you know like
Gene Jacobs she talks about like cities
and how you know they're organic and
when I like some of the mid 20th century
guys the architecture they had removed
shade from uh you know like like awnings
and stuff like that got removed so this
is like the restoration of like awnings
and shade and structure so that you're
not always exposed to the All-Seeing web
crawler that I have soar on which is
like Google botched indexing everything
these are search resistant identities
and that like I just sort of passes over
you like you know in The Terminator like
in The Terminator I just kind of passes
over you right so search identity is not
pulled up it's not indexed right and now
you can be your real self and so we've
had this kind of thing for a while file
with communication the new thing is that
cryptocurrency has allowed us to do it
for transaction hence the pseudonymous
economy right and
um should go from Anonymous pseudonymous
real name these each have their
different purposes but
the New Concept is that pseudonym you
can have multiple of them by the way
your ens name you could have it under
your real name or state name like Lex
friedman.dth but you could also be uh
punk6529.eath okay and now you can earn
you can sign documents you can boot up
stuff you can have a persistent identity
here okay which has a level of
indirection to your real name why is
that very helpful because now it's
harder to both discriminate against you
and cancel you concerns of various
factions are actually obviated or at
least partially addressed by going
pseudonymous as default right it is the
opposite of bringing your whole self to
work it's bring only your necessary self
to work right only show those
credentials that you need right now of
course you know anybody who's in
cryptocurrency understands social
Nakamoto and so on is for this but
actually many progressives are for this
as well why you don't ban the boxes
it's like you're not supposed to ask
about like felony convictions when
somebody is you know being hired because
they've paid they've served their time
right or
um you're not supposed to ask about
immigration status or marital status in
an interview
um and uh you know people have this
concept of blind auditions where you
know uh if a woman is auditioning for
for a like a violin seat they put it
behind a curtain so they can't downgrade
you know her for playing her performance
is judged
on the merits of its audible quality not
in terms of who who this this person is
so this way they don't discriminate
versus male or female for um
for who's uh you know getting a violent
position so you combine those Concepts
like ban the Box not asking these
various questions blind auditions and
and then also the concept of implicit
bias like if you if you you know believe
this research people are unconsciously
biased towards other folks right okay so
you take all that you take Satoshi and
you put it together and you say okay
let's use pseudonyms that actually takes
unconscious bias even off the table
right because
um now you have genuine Global equality
of opportunity moreover you have all
these people billions of people around
the world that might speak with accents
but they type without them and now if
they're pseudonymous you aren't
discriminating against them right
moreover with AI very soon the AI
version of Zoom you'll be able to be
whoever you want to be and speak in
whatever voice you want to speak in
right and um you'll be and they'll
happen in real time uh so I mean this is
really interesting but I
for finsta and rinsta there's some sense
in which the fake Instagram
you're saying is where you could be a
real self well my question is under
uh under pseudonym or when you're
completely Anonymous is there some sense
where you're not actually being your
real self that as a social entity
the the it is human beings are
fundamentally social creatures and for
us to be social creatures there is some
sense in which we have to have a
consistent identity that can be canceled
that can be
criticized uh or applauded in society
and that identity persists through time
so is there some sense in which we would
not be our full beautiful human selves
unless we have
a lifelong consistent real name into
attached to us in a digital world so
this is a complicated topic but let me
make a few remarks first is real names
quote unquote state names were not built
for the internet to actually state names
right it's actually a great way of
thinking about social security name
right
um so your state name your official name
was not built for the internet why they
give both too much information and too
little okay so too much information
because uh someone with your name can
find out all kinds of stuff about you
like for example uh someone doesn't want
to be stalked right
the real name is out there the stalker
knows it they can find address
information all this other kind of stuff
right
um and with all these hacks that are
happening just every day we see another
hack massive hack Etc uh that real name
can be indexed into Data That was
supposed to be private right like for
example you know the office of personnel
management like the government the US
government many governments actually are
like a combination of the uh
surveillance State and the Keystone Cops
right why they they slurp up all the
information then they can't secure it so
it leaks out the back door okay they've
they basically have you know 100 million
records of all just very 300 million
records all this very sense of data they
just get owned hacked over and over
again right and so really there should
be something which totally inverts the
entire concept of kyc and what have you
um and of course comply with the
regulations as they are currently
written but also you should argue
privacy over kyc the government should
not be able to collect what it can't
secure it's slurping up all this
information it's completely unable to
secure it it's hacked over and over
again you know China probably has the
entire OPM file and it's not just that
like Texas is hacked
um and some of these hacks are not even
detected yet right
and these are just ones that have been
admitted and so you know what happens is
criminals can just run this stuff and
find you know okay so that guy who's got
that net worth online and emerges
various databases they've got a bunch of
addresses to go and hit okay so in that
sense real names were not state names
were not built for the internet they
just give up too much information and
are actually existing internet
environment they give up too much
information on the other hand they also
give too little by If instead you give
out uh Lex friedman.eath okay or a
similar crypto domain name or Urban name
or something like that now that's
actually more like a a DNS okay first if
you've got a let's like streaming.eth
what can you do that
um some you can do today some you'll
soon be able to do uh you can pay live
stream you can message live streams.you
can
um look it up like a social profile you
can send files to it you can upload and
download basically it combines aspects
of an email address
um a a a website a username Etc et
cetera where you you know eventually I
think you'll go from email to phone
number to ens address or something like
that as the primary online identifier
because this is actually a programmable
name right whereas a state name is not
you know think about it like a state
name will have apostrophes perhaps in it
or is that your middle name or this and
that that was a format that was
developed for the paper world right
whereas the ens name is developed for
the online world now a reason to say ens
are something like it
you know somebody had a in a village
they'll their name might be Smith
because they were a blacksmith or Potter
because they were Potter right in the
same way I think your surname
right now for many people it's not Ethan
that reflects the ethereum community
your surname online will carry
information about you like dot Saul says
something different about you dot BTC
says yet something different I think
we're going to have a massive
fractionation of this over time we're
still in the very earliest days of our
internet civilization right 100 200
years from now those surnames may be as
informative as say Chen or Friedman or
stream of Austin in terms of what
information they carry because the
protocol is the civilization
fundamentally that you're associated
with right right so that there's some
improvements to the real name that you
could do in the digital world but do you
think there's value of having a name
that's persists throughout your whole
life that is shared
between all the different digital I
think you should have a community I
think you should be able to opt into
that right at which at which level in
terms of the society that you're joining
wait a minute so can I murder a bunch of
people in society one
and then go to society too and be like
I'm murder free my no my name is I don't
mean it like that no yeah so but here's
why that's the application I'm
interested in okay well so what what
resistance
I would like you to talk about me sure a
person who's clearly bad for society
from doing that sure sure murder is
going to be against the rules in almost
every society and I mean basically I
mean people will argue yeah yeah most
likely right and um animals well I'm
thinking of like the Aztecs or the Mayas
or you know something like that there's
various you know Soviet Union there's
weird there's weird edge cases yeah
their societies unfortunately that have
actually that's why that's why
asterisker but let's say
murder is um something that society1
probably has effectively a social smart
contract or a social contract that says
that's illegal therefore you're in jail
therefore you're deprived of the right
to exit but upon entry into that Society
in theory you would have said Okay I
accept this quote social contract right
obviously if I kill somebody I can't
leave okay so you've you've accepted
upon crossing the border into there
right now
um as I mentioned you know uh like what
is murder like people will I mean
there's an obvious answer but as I said
there's been human sacrifice in some
societies communism they kill lots of
people Nazism they kill lots of people
unfortunately there's quite a lot of
societies
you know I wanted to say it's an edge
case but maybe many of the 26th Century
societies around the world have
institutionalized some kind of murder
where there was a Red Terror you know in
the Soviet Union or obviously the
Holocaust or you know the cultural
revolution or year zero and so on and so
forth right so my point there
is that who's committing all those
murders it was the state it was the
organization that one is implicitly
trusting them to track you right and how
do they commit this murders well how did
Lenin you know uh you know the hanging
order I'm talking about the hanging
order for the cool locks yes okay the
famous hanging order which actually
showed they were actually bloodthirsty
the key thing was he said here's a list
of all the quote rich men the cool locks
go and kill them the real names the
state names were what facilitated the
murder
didn't prevent the murderers there right
so my point is
just in the ethical waiting of it it's a
two-sided thing right you're right that
the tracking can you know prevent
disorganized murders but the tracking
facilitates unfortunately organized
murders lists of undesirables were the
primary tool of all of these oppressive
states in the 20th century
you see my point I I see your point and
it's a very strong point
in part it's a cynical point
which is that
the rule of
a centralized state
is
more negative than positive
I think it is a it is like it's like
nuclear energy okay it's it's uh it's
like fire
it is something which
um you're gonna keep having it reform
because there's there's good reasons
where you have centralization
decentralization recentralization but
power corrupts absolute power corrupts
absolutely and you just have to be very
suspicious of this kind of centralized
power the more trust you give it often
the less trusted it deserves
it's like a weird feedback loop right
the more trust the more it can do the
more it can do
the more bad things it will do so okay
there is a lot of downside to the state
being able to track you right and
history teaches us lessons one at a
large scale especially in the 20th
century at the largest of scale a state
can do commit a large amount of murder
and suffering and by the way history
isn't over if you think about what the
Chinese are building on this right that
surveillance State it's not just
tracking your name it's tracking
everything on you you know like WeChat
is essentially like it
it is all the convenience and none of
the freedom so that's the downside but
don't you the question is about is I
think probably fundamentally about the
human nature of an individual
of how
much murder that would be if we can just
disappear every time we murder well I
mean at the individual level so the
issue is basically like once once one
realizes that the moral trade-off has
two pulls to it right and moreover that
basically centralized organized murder
has I mean if we add up all the
disorganized murder of the 20th century
it's probably significantly less than
the organized murder that was that these
states facilitated right and probably by
you know RJ Rummel has this thing called
democide right the thing is it's so Grim
right because you know it's saying like
one one death is a tragedy a million is
a statistic right these are just like
just incalculable tragedies that we
can't even you know uh understand but
um you know nevertheless engaging with
it like you know I don't know it's a
ratio 10x is it 100x I wouldn't be
surprised if it's 100x yeah but have you
seen the viciousness the negativity the
division within online communities that
have anonymity so that's the thing is
basically you there's also a Scylla and
a sharabdis I'm not you know when you
when you see what centralization can do
and you correct in the direction of
decentralization you can over correct
with decentralization and you get
Anarchy and this is basically then you
want to recentralize right and this is
the you know uh I think it's the Romance
of three kingdoms uh the Empire long
United must divide the Empire long
divided must unite that's always the way
of it right so it's going to happen is
we will state certain verbal principles
right and then the question is where in
state space you are are you too
centralized well then okay you want to
decentralize and are you too
decentralized and we want to centralize
it may track more right and people opt
into more tracking because they will get
something from that tracking which is a
great reduced societal stability so so
it's kind of like saying are we going
north or south and the answer is like
what's our destination where's our
current position in the in the
civilizational state space well my main
question I guess is um does uh creating
a network State Escape
from the some of the flaws of human
nature the reason you had got Nazi
Germany
is a large-scale resentment with
different explanations for that
resentment that's ultimately lives in
the heart of each individual they made
up the entirety of Nazi Germany and had
a charismatic leader that was able to
channel that resentment into action into
actual policies into actual political
and Military movements can't you not
have the same kind of thing in digital
communities as well have you heard the
term argumentum ad hitlerum or like
Godwin's law or something like you know
it's something where if the reference
point is Hitler it's just it's this
thing where a lot of things break down
but I do think I mean look is there any
uh did Bitcoin manage to get where it
was without a single shot being fired to
my knowledge yes right it's a Google
managed to get to where it is without
shots being fired absolutely
um and while a lot of shots were being
fired elsewhere in the world sure and
but who's firing those shots right yeah
but that's because Bitcoin and Google
are tiny minority of communities that's
it's like the the icing on the cake of
human civilization sure and basically
any technology I mean like you can use
uh you can use a hammer to go and hit
somebody with it right I'm not I'm not
saying every technology
is equally destructive or what have you
but you can conceive of it's kind of
like rule 34 but for technology right
you okay very you can you can probably
figure out the ability to reference
brilliant things throughout is quite
admirable yes but anyway sorry rule 34
for technology rule three four but for
abusive technology you can always come
up with a black mirror version of
something and in fact there is this kind
of funny tweet which is like a Sci-Fi
author my book don't invent the torment
Nexus was meant to be a cautionary Tale
on what you know would happen if Society
invented the torment necklace and then
it's like uh Tech guys at long last we
have created the torment Exodus right
and uh so the thing is that simply
describing something some abuse
unfortunately
um after the initial shock wears off
people will unconsciously think of it as
sort of an attractor in the space right
it's like I'll give you some examples
like uh you you know Minority Report had
the gesture thing right and the connect
was based on that so it's a dystopian
movie but had this cool kind of thing
and people you know kind of keyed off it
right or you know people have said that
movies like um you know full metal
jacket that was meant to be in my my
understanding is meant to be like an
anti-war movie but lots of you know
soldiers just love it you know despite
the fact that the drill sergeants
actually depicted as a bad guy right for
the sort of portrayal of that you know
kind of kind of environment right so I'm
just saying it's like giving the vision
of like the digital Hitler or whatever
is not actually a vision I want to paint
I do think is it is it everything is
it's possible obviously you know isis
uses the internet right like is it yeah
I'm not we're not bringing up Hitler
in a shallow argument we're bringing up
Hitler in a long empathetic relaxed
discussion which is which is where
Hitler can live in a healthy way so that
there is a there's deep left lessons in
Hitler and Nazi Germany absolutely
Stalin yes okay so in many ways uh you
know and this is a very superficial way
of talking about it but this is
um exit is the anti-genocide technology
right because exit is the route of the
politically powerless exit is not people
always say oh exit is for the rich or
that's actually not true most immigrant
most immigrants equals most immigrants
are not rich they're politically
powerless they describe exit what is
exit so uh there's this you know book
which I reference a lot I like it um
called exit voice and loyalty by Albert
hirshman okay and he essentially says
um and you know I get this talk uh in
2013 that that goes through this uh at
uh YC start school but just to describe
these
voices reform Exodus alternatives for
example in the context of an open source
project voices uh submitting a bug and
exit is forking in a company
um voices uh you're saying you know hey
uh here's a
um here's a ticket okay that I'd like to
get solved and exit is taking your
business elsewhere okay
um you know at level corporate
governance voices you know board
directors vote and exit is selling your
shares right in a country voice is a
vote and exit is migration okay and
um I do think that the two forces we
talk about a lot democracy and
capitalism are useful forces
um but there's a third which is uh
migration right so you can vote with
your ballot you vote with your wallet
you can vote your feet wallet has some
aspects of exit built into it
um but voting your feet actually has
some aspects of voice built into it
because when you leave it's like an
amplifier on your vote you might say 10
things but you actually leave then
people take what you said seriously
you're not just like complaining or
whatever you you actually left San
Francisco because it was so bad on this
and this issue and you've actually voted
with your feet it is
um manifest preference as opposed to
state of preference so Voice versus exit
is this interesting dichotomy do you try
to reform the system or do you exit it
and build a new one or seek an
alternative and then loyalty modulates
this where if you are a patriot as part
of your the initial part of your
conversation right like you know uh are
you are you a Trader you know you're
giving up on our great thing or whatever
right
and you know people push those buttons
to get people to stick that's like you
know I should say the bad version let's
say a common version Sometimes good
sometimes bad
um then uh but then there's the good
version which is oh you know maybe the
price is down right now but you believe
in the cause so even if they're uh you
know on paper you you would rationally
exit you believe in in this thing and
you're gonna stick with it okay so
loyalty can be again good and bad but it
kind of modulates the trade-off between
voice and exit Okay so given that
framework we can think of a lot of
problems in terms of am I going to use
voice or exit or some combination drive
because they're not mutually so that
it's kind of like you know left and
right sometimes you need to build
together
I think that one of the biggest things
the internet does is it increases
microeconomic leverage and therefore
increases exit in every respect of life
for example
um you know on every phone you can pick
between Lyft and Uber right when you're
at the store uh you see a price on the
shelf and you can comparison shop right
um if it's Tinder you can swipe right if
it's Twitter you can click over to the
next account the back button is exit the
The microeconomic Leverage leverage in
the sense of Alternatives right this is
like the one of the fundamental things
that the internet does it puts this tool
on your desktop and now you can go and
talk to an illustrator or you can kind
of build it yourself right by by typing
in some you know characters into Dolly
and that makes the positive forces of
capitalism more efficient uh increase in
microeconomic leverage and it's
individual empowerment right and so our
sort of Industrial Age systems were not
set up for that level of individual
empowerment just to give you like one
example to think about we take for
granted every single website you go and
log into you can configure your Twitter
profile and you can make it dark mode or
light mode and your name all this stuff
is editable right how do you configure
your USA experience
is there a usa.gov that you edit can you
even edit your name there doc mode uh
for USA but I mean just your profile is
there is there like a national profile I
mean there's like driver's license point
is that it's assumed that it's not like
individually customizable quite in that
way right of course you can move around
your house and stuff like that but it's
not like your experience of the US is
like configurable you know uh let me
think about that let me let me think
about sort of the analogy of it so the
microeconomic leverage you can switch
apps
can you switch your experience in in
small ways efficiently multiple times a
day in inside the United States
um well the physical world you do yeah
under the constraints of the physical
world you do like micro migrations so
this is coming back to the
hunter-gatherer farmer Soldier digital
Nomad kind of thing right the
the digital Nomad combines aspects of
the V1 and the V2 for a V3 right because
digital Nomad has the mobility and
freedom of the hunter-gatherer but some
of the consistency of the the
civilization of the farmer and Soldier
right but coming back to this like one
other thing about it is in the 1950s if
a guy in assembly line might literally
push the same button for 30 years okay
whereas today you're pushing a different
key every second
right that is that's like one version of
like microeconomic Leverage another
another version is you know in the 1980s
I mean didn't have Google Maps right so
you couldn't just like discover things
off the path people would just
essentially do you know home to work and
work to home and home to work and a trip
had to be planned right they were
contained within a region of space or
you do home to school school to home
home to school you know it wasn't like
you went and explored the map most
people didn't right they were highly
canalized okay meaning you know that it
was just back and forth back and forth
very routine just like the push the
button push the button trapped within
this very small piece and also trapped
within this large country because it was
hard to travel between countries and so
on again you know of course there were
vacations of course there was some
degree of news and so on your Mobility
wasn't completely crushed but it was
actually quite low okay relatively
speaking just you you were you were
trapped in way you weren't even really
thinking about it okay and now that map
is opened up now you can see the whole
map you can go all over the place
um you know I don't have the data to
show it but I would I'd be shocked if
people the average person didn't go to
more places wasn't you know doing more
you know going to more restaurants and
things like that today than they were in
the 80s simply because the map is open
okay and the the map is made more open
through the digital world to the digital
world exactly so we're reopening the map
like the hunter-gatherer okay because
you can now think about every site for
very low cost that you can visit right
the digital world you can I mean how
many websites have you visited I don't
know hundreds of thousands probably at
this point over your life right how many
places on the services you're actually
unusual you might be like a world
traveler or what have you right but
still even your even your physical
Mobility is less than your digital
Mobility right you can just essentially
I mean the entire Consular like Nations
and borders and whatnot didn't exist in
the hunter-gatherer hour right because
you couldn't
um you couldn't build permanent
fortifications and whatnot even even
Nations as we currently think of them
would like demarcated borders
um you did cartography you needed Maps
right that stuff didn't exist for a long
time you just had sort of a fuzzy area
of we kind of controlled this territory
and these guys are on the other side of
the river okay I think uh just I don't
want to progressed too much but yeah the
word digress away I think entirety of
life on Earth is is a kind of a
digression which creates Beauty and
complexity as part of the digression I
think your vision of the network state
is really powerful and beautiful I just
would want to linger on this let's talk
about a real name issues let me just
give you some data okay a personal
anecdotal experience data there's a
reason I only do this podcast in person
there is something lost in the digital
space oh sure and I find now I
personally believe
to play Devil's Advocate Against The
Devil's Advocate that I'm playing
I personally believe that this is a
temporary thing we will figure out
technological solutions to this but I do
find that currently people are much more
willing to be on scale cruel to each
other online yes and they are in person
uh the only the way to do that just
visit Ukraine went to the front the way
you can have people be cruel to each
other in the physical space is through
the Machinery of propaganda that
dehumanizes the other side right all
that kind of stuff that's really like
hard work to do online I find just
naturally the individual scale people
uh somehow start
to easily engage in the drug of mockery
derision and cruelty yes when they can
hide behind anonymity I don't know what
that says about human nature I
ultimately believe most of us want to be
good and have the capacity to do a lot
of good but sometimes it's fun to be
shitty to [ __ ] on people to be cruel I
don't know what weird is it's weird
because I think you know one of my
sayings is just like the internet
increases in microeconomic leverage the
internet increases variance for anything
that exists before you have you know the
zero and 100 versions of it I'll give
some examples and I'll come to this for
example you go from the 30-minute sitcom
to the 30 second clip or the 30 episode
Netflix binge right you go from guy
working 95 to uh the guy who's the you
know 40 years old and and has failed to
launch hasn't you know the doesn't have
a job or anything and the 20 year old
Tech billionaire okay you go from all
kinds of things that were sort of
gaussian in or kind of constrainable
location to kind of extreme outcomes on
both sides okay and uh applying that
here you are talking about the bad
outcome which I agree does happen where
the internet in some sense makes people
have very low empathy between others but
it also is the other extent where people
find their mental soul mates across the
world someone who's living in Thailand
or in you know like Latin America who
thinks all the same stuff just like them
wow you never met this person before
right you get to know them online you
mean in person it's like you know the
brains have been communicating for two
years three years you've been friends
and you see in person is just great
right so it's actually it's not just the
total lack of empathy it is
frankly far more empathy than you would
be able to build usually with an
in-person conversation in the 80s or the
90s with someone on the other side of
the world because you might not even be
able to get a visa to go to their
country or not even know they existed
how would you be able to be able to find
each other and so on and so forth right
so it is kind of both it is tearing
Society apart and it's putting it back
together both at the same time my main
concern is this what I see
is that young people are for some reason
more willing to engage in the drug of
Cruelty online under the veil of
anonymity that's what you've seen
publicly but you're not seeing the
private chats
like this it's kind of it's a it's a I I
work for the intelligence agency
I'm collecting all of your data uh yeah
yes but you can Intuit stuff and I don't
think I'm being very selective I mean I
I if you if you just look at the Young
Folks I mean I am very concerned
about
the uh the intellectual
psychological growth of young men and
women so I'm I'm not disagreeing with
you on this I am saying however there is
a positive there that once we see it we
can try to amplify that yeah with
technology yes yes I'm just saying the
very very basic technology I give stuff
I I caught up over the weekend kind of
thing I think if I throw an anonymity on
top of that
it will lead to many bad outcomes for
young people anonymity yes pseudonymity
maybe not because Reddit is actually
fairly polite right
um the entirety of Reddit just chuckled
as you said that well well within it
within a subreddit it's actually fairly
polite like they say you're not usually
seeing it depends on which subreddit of
course there's a consistency there's a
right that uh the I think definition of
politeness is interesting here because
it's polite within the culture of that
subreddit yes the abide by let me put it
a different way they abide by the social
norms of that subreddit right and that's
the definition of politeness yeah or
civility is that right so there is an
interesting difference between
pseudonymous and Anonymous you're saying
it's possible that
pseudonymity
you can actually avoid some of the
negative aspects absolutely we're
re-dumbarizing the world in some ways
okay with China being the big
exceptional outlier you know the Dunbar
number 150 people
if you know that that's like roughly the
scale of your Society right
um
or that's the number of people that a
human can kind of keep in in their brand
that's you know whether apocryphal or
not I think I think it's probably
roughly true
and uh
we're re-dumbarizing the world because
a we're making small groups much more
productive and B we're making large
groups much more fractious right so you
have an individual like Notch you can
program Minecraft by himself or Satoshi
you could do V1 and Bitcoin by himself
or you know Instagram which is just like
10 people or Whatsapp which is like 50
people when they sold
um but the other hand you have huge
quote countries of hundreds of millions
of people that are just finding that the
first and second principle or the the
you know they're just splitting on
principal components you know whether
Scott Alexander thinks of them as
scissor statements you know the
statements that one group thinks is
obviously true one group thinks is
obviously false you can think of them as
political polarization you think of it
in terms of Game Theory there's lots of
different reasons you can give for why
this happens but those large groups now
are getting split and so you have both
the unsustainability of these large sort
of artificial groups and the
productivity of these small organic ones
and so that is kind of it's like sort of
obvious that's the direction of
civilizational rebirth we just need to
kind of lean into that
so this thing there's so many beautiful
just like
um you know we mentioned chocolates
right advertising themselves your
entirety speech is an intellectual like
box of chocolates